There are legends in basketball so famous, you
know them by one name. Jordan, kobe, Lebron,
and there is a legend who is status is so iconic,
you know him by one letter, K, as in coach K. For
42 seasons, Mike krzyzewski served as the
head coach for the duke blue devils. He won
five national championships before retiring. I sat
down with him to talk about life, coaching wisdom,
and what is more important than winning.
>> It's a pretty cool view.
>> Yeah.
>> And you know, all the banners and --
>> That's all your national championships.
>> The five, yeah,
and final fours and ACC championships.
>> You're often described by people in profiles of
you as the son of a cleaning woman and an elevator
operator. But I don't think that's how you
[8:44:26 AM]
But I don't think that's how
you would describe your parents.
>> No, my parents were the basis of who me and
my brother became. They taught us the dignity
of work, I even tell my teams for years, I want
you to be as tough as your mother. And just think
about your mother, was there ever a day that she
didn't show up? Did you ever see her sick? Did
you ever see her tired? I never saw my mom sick
or tired. I saw her every day doing everything
that she could possibly do to make it nice for
me and my brother, bill. I didn't appreciate it
until later in life. And my dad died when I was
a senior at west point. He didn't go by the name
krzyzewski, he went by the name "Cross." He was
always afraid of losing his job because there was
a lot of ethnic discrimination at that time. I
didn't realize all the things that my parents --
>> Gave up?
>> Gave up. >> Hid?
[8:45:27 AM]
>> Hid? Your parents didn't even want
you guys to learn to speak Polish.
>> Polish, right.
>> Why?
>> And I didn't find out this until later,
they didn't want us to have an accent,
because they were afraid again -- they're
in that time, somebody with a vowel at the
end of their name may have been looked
at differently. They were concerned.
>> They were trying to protect you.
>> They were trying to protect
me and my brother.
>> So much so that it
wasn't on his tombstone until --
>> Yeah. He was in World War II as
William cross. And so when he died, and we, you
know, were a low-income family, the government
provides a tombstone. It said "Cross." And we
weren't able to change that until my mom passed,
and my brother and I made sure it said krzyzewski.
I was fortunate to be inducted into the basketball
hall of fame in 2001 and one of the parts of the
speech and probably the most emotional for me was,
I said, I wish my mom and dad were
here tonight -- I'm going to start
[8:46:27 AM]
tonight -- I'm going to start crying, to see
a krzyzewski go into the hall of flame. It
was emotional then, it's emotional now, because I
recognized just the life they led to make sure me
and bill would be taken care of. Amazing.
>> How much of what you've done and how
you've led and carried on this
name so proudly, it's so famous.
I just walked in the krzyzewski center.
>> They couldn't find another name for it,
so they put one that no one could pronounce.
>> I love this picture.
>> Yeah. You can tell she's --
>> Proud.
>> I've been married 53 years to Becky
and we knew that it was going to be a partnership.
I call it, two is better than one if two can act
as one. And we were able to act as one. That's
my family. Whenever we played in the olympics,
we brought everybody.
>> You did?
>> Yeah.
>> You did a lot of it all together.
[8:47:28 AM]
together.
>> I have three daughters.
>> They hold you down to Earth?
>> They -- whatever humility I did not have,
they try to interject over and over, so when
there used to be family dinners and people
would eat together, and I would be sitting at
a table with my four girls and we're playing
Carolina or Maryland or whatever, and we just won
a big game, and we're talking and nothing is sad.
>> About your win?
>> Or about the game.
My wife did a great thing, poppy. When all of
my girls were growing up, we never had anything
"Basketball" in the house. The players would come
over, but there weren't trophies, pictures --
>> There was no shrine to coach K. In your house?
>> There is no shrine. And
there shouldn't be, you know.
>> Well, there are in some people's houses.
>> Yeah, now because it's just
me and Nicky and our dog, coach.
>> There's a shrine?
>> Well, I'm in a basement
office -- well, the lower level -- and
can I put anything I want in there.
[8:48:29 AM]
I want in there. So. Whenever I need my ego
boost, I go down there and start -- man,
you were really good. No, I don't do that.
>> Do you ever come stand here alone?
>> I do. Usually -- not a lot, but later
at night when all the lights are out,
there might be just a little bit on the national
championship banners or whenever you walk in and
you feel like you're in a field of dreams.
>> This is your field of dreams?
>> Yeah, or you feel like, I better get out
of here, because the basketball god's are
going to play pickup here in a little bit.
>> There are stars, there are star players,
but we've seen in college basketball,
in the NBA, that when you just put a
bunch of stars together, it often doesn't work.
>> You heard that expression, leave your egos at
the door. I hate that expression.
>> You do?
>> I hate it.
>> Bring your ego?
>> Bring everything you've got. Bring who you
are. Why would you leave something you are --
>> To make room for others?
>> No, we should make the room
[8:49:29 AM]
>> No, we should make the room bigger.
You know, you're not confined by the room,
when you bring all the egos in and put them
under one umbrella, that's what we did for you,
and it said "Usa" on it, and then you develop
common ground. You want a quick story?
>> Yeah. I want all the stories.
>> Jason kit, first practice, our captain,
hall of famer, leading a fast break drill,
Dwyane wade is in one lane, Lebron's in another,
and the ball's going everywhere. So I bring them
together, and I know we can't play like this,
before I say anything, Jay Kitt says, coach,
I'll tone it immediately kobe, Lebron,
Dwayne said, no, no, no, we've never played
with a talent like you. We'll adapt to you.
>> Really?
>> Yes. It was one of the great moments in my
coaching career where I saw talent say, come on,
talent, give me more. It was like the piano player
[8:50:30 AM]
It was like the piano player telling the sax
player, come on, go, I can play the piano better,
singer. All of a sudden if you can get everyone
playing with all their talent, why wouldn't you
want talent to maximize?
>> Yes.
>> And it doesn't mean you have to
give up talent to maximize. And if
all that works together, wow.
>> How many presidents have you
met? All of them in your lifetime
>> All of them. Even when we W,
in 41 president bush became a close friend.
>> This is you and kobe.
>> Yeah, this is U.S., thanks for all
the golden moments. This is a great book
for me because each player gave their quote.
>> So can we read what Lebron said about you.
>> Yeah.
>> He allows us to play the game
of basketball and just go out there and have fun,
but at the same time he wants us to be perfect.
[8:51:30 AM]
perfect. We should expect perfection and that
is what he is about. We like that. We like that
kind of challenge.
>> Yeah.
>> Read the last line kobe said about you.
>> Coach K. Is one of the best coaches of
all time, period, no question about it.
>> One of the things that I've learned
about you is how hard you are on yourself.
And that there have been moments when you
will actually -- Yo looked in the mirror
over your career and cursed yourself out.
>> We are all better if we are held
accountable. You know, how you hold
players accountable along the years change
but you still have to hold them accountable.
>> You've been tough on them, very.
>> Well, you hold them accountable. Sometimes
there's nobody that holds the leader accountable,
it's on you, I did it, you know, I need to change.